now my brain dump
well it's apparently victory day in
russia and vladimir putin's been flexing
his supposed military muscle in a north
korea-style parade that will make even
kim jong-un look bashful but the only
victory that putin's marking this year
is becoming the world's biggest loser he
lost the first major battle in ukraine
on the capitol keeve he lost as many as
25 000 troops and 38 colonels on the
battlefield he's lost the global safe
havens for the blood-soaked oil billions
of him and his oligarch cronies he's
also turned russia into the most hated
country on earth so for him to stand
there celebrating victory is a
disingenuous farce but the most savage
irony of putin's victory day is it in
fact marks russia's triumph over nazi
germany the soviet union lost more men
to fighting fascism in world war ii than
any other country 27 million soviets
died for the cause they fought so their
grandchildren could live in peace
but instead putin's chosen war and who
are the nazis today
putin's genocidal rampage has left sways
of ukraine a once flourishing european
sovereign democracy looking more like
london in the blitz
smoke choking the skylines families
huddling for refuge in metro stations
homes blasted into charred remains
and like hitler putin's a delusional
dictator who thinks it's fine to invade
neighboring countries murder journalists
rule by spreading lies and propaganda
even has his own sick swastika
he's not saving ukrainians from the new
nazis as he so outrageously claims putin
is the 21st century hitler and his
bloodthirsty forces are the real new
nazis he's right to say though that
ukraine needs denotifying it does from
him
well for all their spin and bluster
local elections have left both of
britain's big party leaders with a big
black eye and a bloody nose and frankly
they deserve it leadership in uk
politics is in a very sorry state
boris johnson's tourist lost 487 seats
and 12 councils but despite that
disastrous shellacking party insiders
say boris is buoyant and remains an
asset really that's the kind of thing
that putin's few remaining colonels are
probably saying about their beleaguered
boss
meanwhile opposition leader uh sakir
stama who should have been celebrating
winning 108 new seats for this labour
party is instead been tied up in an
increasingly tight knot of his own
making over breaking lockdown rules
after months of taking the moral high
ground against boris johnson for his
illicit downing straight parties today
starmah dramatically upped the ante by
announcing that he will resign if police
find him over the apparently illicit
beer and curry soiree that he shared
with his campaign staff it's an
amazingly high stakes gamble and of
course would put johnson under huge
pressure to do the same if he does have
to quit but i suspect hypocrisy and
lying might finish them both off
whatever happens boris broke the rules
he set for the rest of us and then
repeatedly lied about it starmer said
that boris must resign when police
investigated now the same thing's
happened to him but he hasn't resigned
he just committed to resign if he gets
fined
and as the two of them squabble over
this kind of nonsense and fight for
their political lives the united kingdom
is now facing the very real prospect of
being slowly but surely broken up in a
shock development in northern ireland
nationalist party shin fame which once a
united ireland won the biggest number of
seats for the first time and i fear that
may be the catalyst for the slow
breakdown of the entire united kingdom
coming at the time when the scottish
national party in scotland is also
growing in strength
the seeds in ireland were sown when
brexit when britain signed a brexit deal
that built a trade barrier down the iris
sea and marked off northern ireland from
the rest of the uk having repeatedly
assured us that wouldn't happen would be
totally unacceptable it was a fudge then
and a betrayal and it was never going to
stick and nationalists have now moved to
exploit that vacuum if the uk is going
to stay together and i hope it does it
needs strong leaders in westminster who
earn the public's trust instead we can't
trust the current crop to run a welt
stool
if you asked me to name one of the most
enduring loves of my life other than
arsenal football club it would be the
humble london black cat a purring sleek
glossy emblem of britain always there
when you need it safe secure symbolic
sexy
as iconic to the capital city as red
buses bowler hats and
but it's in a different league to those
cheap inferior postures like uber
well of course if the busy bodies get
their way and they're trying now this
might be the end of the road for the
black cabs as we know it now i happen to
think the black cabs are not just far
superior to their brothers they're in a
different class there's no flapping
around on the street trying to find your
driver for half an hour before he
cancels on you no secret spiteful little
rating system who wants to be rated by a
cab driver no following the sat nav down
blind alleys now black cabs show up you
tell the cabbie where you want to go and
he or she will take you there on the
fastest route possible and they don't
need any fancy map to do it the reason
they're able to do it so efficiently is
because of the knowledge now for the
uninitiated the knowledge is the
staggeringly difficult examination all
london black cab drivers have to pass to
qualify it dates back 170 years it takes
about four years to complete and it
requires personal knowledge of 25 000
roads and 20 000 landmarks black cab
drivers don't need satellites because
they've got the knowledge and in
exchange for that knowledge they get
special privileges like being able to
use bus lanes and pick customers up at
the roadside they're not just national
treasures their global treasures without
any doubt the finest and best qualified
cab drivers on the entire planet
but now the busy bodies i mentioned
earlier at an influential think tank say
the knowledge and all of those perks
should be scrapped they say the
revolution in consumer choice means that
app-based services should get all the
same entitlements to bring taxis into
the modern age without any need for the
knowledge
this is nonsense
shameful nonsense it must be thwarted
the knowledge is what makes our cab
drivers the best in the world black cab
drivers should be deemed an official
endangered species and protected
accordingly the campaign to save the
black cab
starts here
what do black cab drivers actually do
they drive cabs right just as a baker
bakes and a funeral director directs
funerals so what about an actor
when they act right it's literally that
simple
only in these woke ravaged days it's
obviously not allowed to be that simple
the outgoing boss of the royal
shakespeare company says only disabled
people should be able to play richard
iii because the king was disabled this
isn't the first time we've heard this
virtue signaling claptrap brian cranston
was flamed for playing a
wheelchair-bound guy in the upside eddie
redmayne got hammered for playing
disabled astro genius stephen hawking
and then pressured into a groveling
apology when he played a trans character
in the danish girl scalia hansel was
slammed the starring in a movie based on
a japanese manga comic because she's not
japanese which is not a cartoon either
and the same people enraged by these
supposedly inauthentic portrayals have
no problem seeing black actors playing
leading roles in period dramas even if
that is historically wrong and they
shouldn't have a problem with it because
they're actors who are acting that's the
whole point of acting
if the wokies get their way the next
person to play hitler in a movie will
have to be a genocidal nazi and that
means only vladimir putin might qualify
last time i checked as his performance
as a global peacemaker shows his
thespian skills leave a lot to be
desired
but i'm sure there's one thing we can
all agree on and it's this this
is not acting
so i'm here to rate you on your recent
visit to aotearoa in new zealand in
2018. okay you'll be moderately happy to
know that you scored three stars three
stars out of what
100 100 no out of five okay very funny
yeah that's privity previously shy
prince harry uh on tv again making his
acting debut in a ridiculous new zealand
advert for his eco travel non-profit
harry clearly is not just a terrible
actor he's also a terrible hypocrite a
guy who constantly preaches about the
environment but uses private jets like
iu's black cabs this is like adele
lecturing us about how not to be a diva